And now the old scout master.
Tom, you know why you can't starve to death in the desert?
Uh no,
Because of all the sandwiches there.
Oh,
There's your cut-in right there.
Clearly he'd been thinking grand in the back of the boys' lives.
How many of our sons you know? that's the first page they turn to in the magazine.
Oh yeah,
That's the one I look at.
We could tell:
Hey, this is podcast number 110..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Good to have you back.
Let's look in the mailbag.
Brody wrote in.
He said I am currently working on my queen scout in Australia.
Just like to say how helpful and awesome your site is.
Best wishes.
Thanks very much, Brody.
Sure, do appreciate that.
Australia,
How about that?
I think that's the first message I've read on the podcast from Australia.
So the rest of you Aussies down there,
Let's write in.
Let me know you're out there.
Tom Gillard said very good show this week.
He's referring to podcast number 109..
Bob Mazooka had some good insights into what volunteers are doing.
I really like the closing.
It'll be hard to top that one.
Thanks very much, Tom.
You know, Tom, one of the interesting things is that many listeners write in and tell me
how much they like it when the show closes.
I don't know if they meant it the same way that you did.
Well, anyway,
Scout Master Jerry tweeted: just listen to Scout Master Podcast with Bob Mazooka-
Terrific show.
You also take the time to listen.
Well done, Clark.
Well, thank you very much, Jerry.
Jerry has the SMM podcast and the Scout Masters Minute blog.
Make sure you get over and take a look.
Kayleigh Gallapo is up in Canada and she was mentioned last week
but now she's been mentioned twice and I've gotten her name right twice.
Hey, Kayleigh.
Phil Peck on Google Plus said: Clark Green has made it to the big leagues,
Bob Mazooka.
Well done, sir.
Can't wait to listen to the podcast.
And then Adam Cox replied.
He said I would say that Bob made it to the big leagues.
Yes, well,
Now it was quite exciting to have the Chief Scout Executive on last week
and I have returned to Earth.
So in this show we have a Scout Master panel discussion
and I think you're going to find it useful.
It's about the troop committee
and we kind of majored on the relationship between the Scout Master
and the troop committee.
We were very fortunate to get Frank Maynard to call in
and talk with us for the panel discussion.
Frank is the author of Bob White Blather.
You'll see him referred to fairly often on my blog
and he returns the favor on his.
But Frank is a committee chair
and has a lot of good things to say.
So the panel discussion is going to take up the rest of the podcast,
So let's get started, shall we?
It's time for another Scout Masters panel discussion,
And joining us tonight we've got Tom Gillard.
Tom is down in Tallahoma, Tennessee.
How are you doing, Tom
Good Clark? How are you?
I'm hanging in there.
Walter came back from over there in Hawaii
and he's back joining us.
At what location? this time? around, Walter.
I'm once again on the 14th floor.
It's a beautiful, clear day here.
I can see Mount Tam- that's probably 60 miles away.
Oh wow,
And that's in California.
What part of California? again?
Santa Clara,
And Larry Geiger in Vieira, Florida.
How are you doing, Larry
Good Clark? Good evening,
Good to hear from you,
And joining us is- I've captured a Bob White.
If you are out there on the interwebs
and you are looking for scouting information,
you may have run across his blog- Bob White Lather.
And we have Frank Maynard joining us this evening.
How are you doing, Frank?
Hey Clark, it's good to be with you guys.
So, Frank, what part of the world are you in?
Well, I'm in Novi, Michigan, which is in southeast Michigan.
It's sort of between Detroit and Ann Arbor.
We are in the Great Lakes Council currently,
but we are in the midst of what is shaping up
to be a possibly more widespread phenomenon
where councils are actually merging
into large area-wide councils-
The Area 2 project. you may have heard about
and probably read in Scouting Magazine this month-
And we're right in the thick of it here.
The Greater Michigan Council was just formed
and we're going to be folded into that pretty soon.
You're working with which troop there?
I work with Troop 407, which is in Novi.
We've been in business for close to 30 years.
We have 58 scouts- actually 59 scouts currently-
and we're expecting to add another 08 to 10,
perhaps with the Weeblows crossovers this spring,
back to our normal strength of about 68,
where we've been for the last- oh, I'd say
three or four years,
And we got there through a concerted effort
of marketing to the Weeblows scouts.
It does work. folks,
You are currently serving as the committee chairman.
That's right, I'm the committee chair.
I've been in committee chair for five years.
Prior to that, I was on the troop committee as a.
my function was the Weeblows resource person
And I go back to Cub Scouts as Cub Master,
Weeblows leader, Den leader and assistant Cub Master.
What we hear from Frank on his blog
is things concerning the troop committee.
He's had some really excellent advice on there
and a series of posts about running committee meetings
and things like that that I think you will find very useful,
And we'll make sure to link to his blog
in the post that contains this podcast.
We've got him here to talk about
the Scoutmaster troop committee relationship a little bit.
Sometimes they're pulling against each other,
but what we're always looking for
is that kind of well-balanced relationship.
We're getting the program to the boys.
What's the best way, Frank,
to get the committee chair and the Scoutmaster
pulling in the same direction?
Well, I think the easy answer to that
is that, since the committee chair is responsible
for selecting the other adult leaders,
he just needs to select a Scoutmaster he can work with.
But that's not always possible.
A lot of times the committee chair will come into a situation
where a Scoutmaster's been around for a while
and is entrenched.
He doesn't have the opportunity to select,
to hand pick a Scoutmaster
and maybe doesn't have the experience to do so.
So I think you really have to develop
a sense of cooperation between
the committee chair and the Scoutmaster,
And it's got to be mutual, so that each respects each other
and hopefully each is on the same page.
It really takes a clear understanding of each other's role
and a willingness to really do your best
in your own area of responsibility
in order to make things work.
Because if there's friction between the two-
where the Scoutmaster wants to depart from the Scouting Program
the way it should be done, for instance,
or where the committee chair tries to push things around
that the Scoutmaster doesn't want to do,
then you really won't have an effective troop for the boys.
Let's start with you, Walter.
What was your relationship with your committee chair
as a Scoutmaster?
Well, my committee chair was somebody I worked with
as a Cubmaster as well.
We both moved on to the troop,
And so we were already a good combination.
Typically, I'm not very good at some of the things
that committee chairs are supposed to do,
so I'm glad to split the job up
and let them have their run.
Right now we have an interesting situation
where we have both the Scoutmaster
and the committee chair stepping down,
So we're looking for a new team.
And, Tom, how about you?
We've got a real good relationship
with the committee chairman.
He understands what I'm trying to do,
what the whole goal of the Scouts
and the boy led,
And he's behind it 100%
And it's very, very lucky
that it's working out real well for me.
And Larry, how about you?
I basically had three committee chairs
and two troops.
Basically, we worked as a team.
I had one for a couple years
and we started a new troop
And I had a guy that was there for eight years.
He had four sons and he was really into everything,
But he was very business-like
and ran a very good meeting
And before long he had about 20, 25 people in his meeting.
The current troop that I just retired from
had another great guy.
Now in my committees I've always had
probably slightly more committee members
than assistants on campouts,
So I've had a pretty good participation
from committee members.
We've all had some very good relationships
with our committees, our committee chairs.
How do we define what Scoutmasters
and assistant Scoutmasters do
and what the committee does?
Let me throw that over to Frank for a minute.
It's really fairly simple.
Actually, we talked about this
at a roundtable discussion last year
which we called which lane are you in?
We explored the subject and it's pretty simple
to define what the committee's job is.
If you look in, I think it's chapter four
of the troop committee guidebook.
it lists the things the committee
is directly responsible for:
Things like ensuring qualified leadership
is on hand and trained,
Providing the meeting room and the meeting facilities
and making sure it's safe. responsible
for finance, property,
facilitating the outdoor program,
supporting advancement, conduct boards of review,
help with friends of scouting
And the rest of the responsibilities.
basically directly support
the Scoutmaster in the program,
Advised on policies of the BSA
and the chartered organization,
supports the Scoutmaster
in working with individual boys
who might need a little bit of additional assistance
and in general support the direct leaders.
The Scoutmasters biggest job,
also referred to in the troop committee guidebook,
is to train and guide the boy leaders.
Everything else pretty much falls under that heading.
He works with the other leaders,
the other assistant Scoutmasters,
to use the methods of scouting
to achieve the aims of scouting.
He meets with the parents
to explain the program to them
and he advises the patrol leaders council.
So just as the interface between the adults
and the boys is between the Scoutmaster
and the senior patrol leader.
the interface between the program
and administrative half is between
the Scoutmaster and the committee chair.
That's where those two come together
and our goal in scouting really-
and you think about it- is not to manage
paperwork but really is to instill
the values in the young people.
This is done through the program side.
the committee has to be there,
has to understand that its most important role
is to support the Scoutmaster
and indirectly then through the boys,
through the various things that they do.
Training is emphasized for
the Scoutmaster and assistant Scoutmasters,
who are more directly involved
with camping trips and things like that.
but we don't really think about
the fact that we need to train the committee as well.
Yes, absolutely, there is
training available. it's
nicely done in person and best done
as a
an entire committee- the troop committee challenge-
and it's also
available online. so there's really no excuse
for not taking it and it does
give a really clear view of
what the committee's job
is and what the various roles are.
I've really stressed- and my committee chairman
have also- that
the main committee chair
people have to get committee training,
treasures
advancement
committee chairs, and everybody's been on board with that.
there's always a couple of committee members
that may not have done that in the past
one or two, but they're usually not that active.
I guess some people think,
oh, that's a goofy little three hour course.
well, people over and over again
tell me: boy, I was sure glad I took that.
It's now also one of the standards
for the journey to excellence.
When our council now they can't register
training, they have to have youth protection,
introduction to scouting
and troop committee challenge.
we're-
what do you call that? prototyping that in our council.
Walter and Tom, are you seeing that?
Not the committee
not, but it is a good idea.
I need to pass that through
our committee chairman.
we're working up to it.
we have the youth protection required for everybody
and working and
they're strongly suggesting
training. One of the things I think
is interesting and might be
a source of confusion
between scoutmasters and committee chairs
is that nowhere in the scoutmasters
handbook does it say what the duties of a
scoutmaster are. It only
says that in the committee materials,
which of course you never look at, it's a scoutmaster.
I never even knew they were there,
so it's really kind of
odd. but once you
look at it it makes a lot of sense
and in fact it reminds me of our church,
Episcopal church, where you've got the priestess
for the spiritual life
of the congregation and the vestries
keeping the lights and the heat on
and it's a little bit like that.
the program and the boys and ASMs are the
scoutmaster and
keeping it all running, taking over
as the committee.
Your number one item in your job description
is all other duties as
assigned and that kind of applies to the scoutmaster
because it's not
a list of responsibilities,
but the responsibility is to
make sure that the boys have the resources
and the training they need to run their program
basically, and that's it, and it varies
from troop to troop tremendously.
So the committee
challenge can be either online
or a face-to-face
setting. Yeah, that's right. It's available
as an online course through the
online learning center.
I've seen that part.
It can also be run by the district
training teams or, for that matter,
if you want to get the materials, you can buy them
and do it yourself.
I'd recommend that you get in touch with your district
training people to maybe get some assistance
with it- One of the other hats that I wear
is the training hat
in our district- and
check with your district training people
and see if they'd be willing to come out to your troop,
maybe get the other troops in town together
for an evening and do the course.
What's the time frame on that? It takes about three
hours.
I think the best way to take that class
is at a district
event with people from other
units.
I think it's very valuable.
We're all serving troops
of at least 25 or more
at this point. Am I right about that?
everybody? Yeah, that's right.
A lot of
times these dynamics in a larger troop
are going to be different from
a smaller troop.
We're also all serving
in troops that have
some history behind them
and have been around for a while,
and the dynamics of this are going to be different
in a newer
troop. because I end up hearing from
a lot of
scout leaders who are working with
newer troops and
smaller troops, let's say,
maybe anywhere from a dozen
to 20 scouts.
When we're looking at this from a smaller scale,
what are the differences there?
It's like similar to
moving parents moving from Cubs
if they've been
in a Cub Scout pack.
that committee is very, very different
because there's no PLC and there's no
program outside of the adults
and so they're not used to splitting that up
at all.
That's part of it if they're coming over from that.
The other is that things are much less formal
in a smaller group. You kind of keep track
of them in your head, but people are doing
a lot of different things and everybody pitches in.
When you look at the
committee guidebook, Frank, how many people
are on a committee?
It really varies and can be as many
as you have, but
there are maybe a half a dozen or so
specific positions that are
called out. When you have a smaller troop,
you might only be able to get a half a dozen
people and get all the roles filled, but otherwise
you're going to have situations where one person
is doing two or three jobs and then they can't
really do them
as well as they could otherwise if they
only had one.
The danger there is that your scout
master or assistant scout masters may
feel compelled to start
picking up some of the slack as well,
and that's not a good situation because that
takes their attention away from the boys
in the program.
When I started troop 709 we had
a couple of leaders, but there were basically
two of us, the committee chairman and myself-
and we just agreed to do everything
and he took the committee stuff
and I took the scout master
stuff and we had 12 scouts.
and the reason I'm saying that
is because what we did was,
as people came along,
we let them just kind of hang around
and figure out what they wanted to do. and,
just me speaking, I don't like pushing
people too hard. I like them
to pick what they want to do and then they
stay at it for six or seven years.
Okay, 19 years ago, when we
first started,
we had crossed over
from Cubs and we knew that we should
have a committee. well, it was
me and my wife would show up
at the gym
and we would be the only two there
and there was five of us- I mean, there were
five kids in the troop at the time-
and as the
years went on and we
would slowly get one
or two more people involved and
you finally get that critical mass
that starts the whole thing rolling
again. and
at some point we got committee
chairman and the treasurer
and the whole gambit
and we were able to step away
and do what we're supposed to do.
Well, people don't have to start
there, do they? I mean people don't have
to start with a committee full
of folks. I mean we just saw two examples
of that, but you do need to have
in your mind that that needs
to build over time.
Yes, absolutely.
You don't ever want it to be where you hang
on to that. it's just
a starting point.
That's. the advantage to having a smaller
unit is that you don't have quite as much
work to do, there's not as much equipment to
manage, you don't have as many scout
accounts to keep track of, so the work
isn't quite as voluminous as it would be
for a troop of 50 or 60 scouts.
So you could probably get along with a smaller
committee. but as the troop grows
and scout membership, you're also gaining
families you need to add
to the committee.
We just crossed over six scouts
last weekend
and
this past Monday was the first time
that the committee met during
a troop meeting and it was
wonderful for me.
It was standing room only
in the little room
where they normally meet. you know
five or six- now was
probably 15
and
I was first on the agenda. did my
report got up? excuse myself,
got up and left,
which is very strange because that's the
first time in 19 years I don't know what
happened at a committee meeting.
so great
way to go,
way to go.
you're almost there, dude,
working at it
well if things are working well, you can sit in on
that committee meeting for most of the troop
meeting and not even have to worry about
how things are going out in the other room.
well, I think Tom wanted to get out of the
committee meeting. that's what I think.
I don't blame them.
some of them can go on and on
if they're not managed. probably
was I right about that, Tom.
yeah, because
my place is
more out there with the kids.
no, I have
committee meetings. we should
talk about this for a moment because it can
actually. it can kind of make or
break the effectiveness of
a unit in some
ways, and
it can certainly make or break your own
kind of peace of mind.
Frank, what do we do
to keep the meetings from being eternal?
that's a good question.
I talked about that a little bit
in my post this week about
avoiding what's called death by
meeting, or at least a term that I
had heard before.
the number one advice is
to have an agenda and stick to it.
start and end your meetings on time.
don't let discussion get off track.
make sure that every agenda item
has a person responsible
for it and make sure that the
outcome of each item on the agenda
is stated,
or at least the desired outcome.
you need to know when you have
finished with something. you need to know
when you have succeeded
at a particular item.
what success looks like, I think
is how it's commonly said.
but keep things moving. if
discussion gets off track,
you kind of have to round things up and move along,
because- and this is where the committee chair
kind of has to have a gentle-
but in persistent hand
in running things, it's the committee chair
loses track of or loses
control of the meeting or the discussion.
then you could be there all night.
so one of the nice things I found,
we recently, within
the last couple of months, moved to having our
committee meetings at the same time as the troop meetings,
and that forces us
to start and end on time, because the boys
are really knocking down the door
when they're done. if we're not done
so, we have to keep the discussion limited
to an hour and a half, and fortunately
we've been well able to do that.
one of the things you don't do is overload
the agenda with stuff that doesn't
really need to be brought up in the meeting.
reports, for instance, can be distributed
ahead of time by email
or just covered very briefly,
you don't have to go on and on. and
I kind of pulled a flip flop this year
by moving the report section from the
committee members to the end of the meeting,
because I was finding that they were taking up
probably a good half of the meeting at the beginning
and we weren't getting to the business end
until you know, until now,
45 minutes in. so this
kind of limits the time for discussion
on those items. but do keep a firm
hand on the agenda and keep it moving.
that's the best advice.
yeah, and also
that scout mat, since we're
scout mastering, that scout master guy,
he needs
to do a scout master minute and go,
and
and that's a place where sometimes-
because a lot of discussion
happens around camp
outs or other things,
the committee chair really needs to like
say: well, we'll work on that during
the outdoor chairman stuff and
so thank you, mr scout master.
you know, after 10, 15,
20 minutes
he kind of needs to go.
yeah, Frank, what do you want to hear from the scout master at a committee meeting?
well, I'd like to hear an update
on how the boys
are doing, what the program,
what his perspective of what the boys
program is all about.
we always have
an item, a line item, for the scout master
and the senior patrol leader
to report. SPL is always welcome
to sit in on the meetings and in fact,
and when we had them on nights other than
the committee meeting nights, sometimes
he'd sit in through the whole meeting just
get a good earful of how the committee works.
and he does kind of need to know that there's this other
side of the troop that that runs the business,
and but he's always welcome
to sit in and I always ask him to come in and give
a report and in fact we had
our committee meeting last night. he came
in, gave a nice report
on the on the outcome of the PLC,
had some really clear ideas and
a lot of things that we had already talked
about. he brought up and that thought
that these were the sorts of things that they wanted
to do and I always
float that item. that item is variable.
it depends on when he can make it in.
if we're in the middle of a troop meeting
time and he's got a couple
minutes to run, in will interrupt our
discussion and let him have his
five minutes on the floor. likewise for the
scout master,
and he may have scout master conferences
to hold and other things as well. so
so those positions
are floated in the
agenda and they can step in
whenever they have a second. Walter, did you
have like a pretty standard approach
to a committee meeting? did you have a report
that you prepared in advance? or
I tended to talk about what was
coming up, a little bit of report on.
maybe, if there's something, some issue with
attendance on campouts- and often
it was- this is this aspect
of scouting which maybe you haven't done before,
or how it's important to get
the new scouts to summer camp
and why that's important.
or we got to start looking at we below, so
just those program related,
what are we thinking about this month
and the next couple of months? from
that, I do bring in
the SPL
often if there's something
we're going to do or explain,
just bring him in and have him
explain it. and Tom, what about you?
I report to him about
what, what's happened,
campery wise
or like, like Walter
said, what's coming up, some of the stuff that
I hear it around table,
that maybe they they haven't heard
training opportunities
and
just miscellaneous stuff,
and just the general health
of the truth, Larry, anything, anything different
from either of those lists,
usually a discussion with the outdoor chairman about
where the camp out is,
any details, kind of in front of the whole
committee. but otherwise,
just like what Walter said, do assistant
scout masters, do they attend the committee
meeting? Frank, ours usually
do. I know that they're technically not members
of the committee but they
have great input and they have good
participation and they care about the
troop. and since we've kind of gotten
gotten away from voting on things
rather than,
what we're doing now is getting more to
agreement, rather than taking a black
and white vote, an up or down vote
on on issues,
we discuss something until we're generally
on agreement of something, it doesn't really matter
that they, that they don't have a vote,
they have a voice and any parent
has a voice on our committee. so
we we invite
all the parents to come and sit in and talk
so so that that sort
of distinction of who is a voting member
of the committee, so to speak, is
kind of faded in our in our troop. but yeah,
the assistant scout masters do come
and and contribute to the to the discussion.
Walter, assistant scout masters
at the committee we do bring in, say,
the venture.
we have a liaisons for different
patrols and one of them to the
venture patrol. so if we
say it's time to start thinking about film on
two years from now or whatever
the planning horizon is,
then they'll come in and talk about
the high adventure stuff,
those kinds of things,
or or maybe I'd have somebody
report on who was one of the leaders
at our summer camp
and and report on that.
but mostly- and we do have a parent
slash committee meeting, so we have
and similar kind of consensus approach
to it. Tom, what about you?
assistant scout masters?
yes,
this time everybody
was in there and I guess
we have morphed into what frank
was talking about, where it's not
just committee members but
the. if there was a parent
standing around, we say, come on.
normally
they show up or they don't.
but if they were standing around
Monday night we invited them to come into the committee
meeting. so I guess it's
morphing into that to some extent. Larry,
what about you? No,
no assistance. sometimes
they transition from the committee
or back to the
committee, but usually
it's just me or me and the senior patrol
leader, and you know we
just visit, stop by and and leave.
we also have a former scout master
who's re-registered as a committee member
because he likes doing boards or review
and he's really good at it. so that's
really an interesting option for
these older, for these ASMs
who the kids have moved on
it's if they want to do boards,
they should register as committee members.
yeah, I've thought about that. in fact,
we had it one a few years ago,
shortly after we joined
the troop. it's probably been about 10 years now.
the scout master
at the time when we joined
re-registered
as the committee,
a member of the committee, and then
became the committee chair for a while
while we were in between committee chairs,
and so he basically
wore every hat in the troop at one point or another
and was
was valuable in the sense that
he could bring the scout master's perspective
over to the committee side, and
we all learned a lot from him
in that regard. Let's talk about the place
of voting
as far as a committee is concerned, because
I think a lot of people make the assumption
that the troop committee should
vote on different questions.
you have trended more towards
just developing consensus
and moving forward. Do you see that
as being a better option than voting?
Yeah, definitely I think it is, because
it really brings out the discussion
and it brings out the pros and cons
and it lets you really
see the other person's point
and if you can all agree
on a course of action,
then I think that it's a much more effective
outcome than it would be
if you had
12 people on the committee
and 7 people voted yes and 5 people voted no.
then you'd have 5 angry people,
or at least disappointed people who
really couldn't support the decision that the rest of them did.
so I think what you have to do
is listen to what everybody has to say
and then try to craft an outcome that
satisfies at least the high points
or at least gives everybody something to celebrate
or something to embrace.
every issue is not
a black and white issue
and there are many aspects to them.
we had a similar issue
within the last year and we reached
a very good compromise
that really pleased the people that were
complaining about the situation
as well as the people that were advocating it.
so I think if you do open the discussion
and just say:
are we all in agreement with this
or what do we not agree about
and how can we smooth it out,
and that's kind of where the committee chair has to guide the discussion
and see where everybody stands-
there are really two.
when you look at a meeting facilitator,
you look at two different roles.
one of the roles is the
impartial arbitrator,
somebody whose job it is to just
look at everybody's viewpoint
and really not inject your own viewpoint into it,
and that's the role that the committee chair has to take
in situations like that
where you've got a divergence of opinion
and you're trying to reach a consensus.
I think we're mostly
with Frank on that
consensus on most things
it's just everybody okay with that.
but occasionally something comes up
and you just, for instance,
how you're going to spend some money.
sometimes you just have to make a decision
and sometimes there's just a couple of people
that want to go another way.
I think almost everything our committees
have done
it's just like: okay. everybody says
yeah, it's unanimous,
I agree with that.
but occasionally
we just kind of cut things off
and said: vote,
okay, we're moving forward.
we spent three meetings on this.
we got to get off this subject.
we're not going to all agree,
and then 99% of what we do
everything else is like: oh yeah, go ahead
a lot of time. if you have a
really complex issue,
you need to have a subcommittee to discuss it
and bring it back the following month,
so you're not tying up committee meeting time.
there is lots and lots of discussion,
they finally get into agreement
and there is still a vote,
but usually it's unanimous vote.
so it's like Larry said: it's 99%
of the time it's everybody's in agreement
and everything's fine. but
we do the same thing.
Walter, you want to weigh in on that?
I know there's some situations where we voted
but I cannot remember what they were
and of course
I'm not in there for most of the meeting.
but we're mostly almost all consensus
voting
and the way that meetings work
and things like that
are sometimes aimed at resolving conflicts.
can anyone talk about an example
of a conflict
that has been resolved within a troop
through the committee?
yeah, we've had
one very large issue
many a few years ago
and it was handled.
it was handled
internally through the committee
and that didn't satisfy.
that wasn't satisfactory
for those involved.
so we had to call in
the district exec
and try and settle
something that way. but the committee chairman
was very professional
and kept his cool,
kept his.
he was pretty much
to the facts and tried not to
put his judgment in on it.
but
it was a bad
one of those bad situations
that
he had to deal with.
the committee resolves things,
but generally not usually in the meeting.
usually a couple of people
and the committee chairman will get together.
let me chime in here, if I may.
the
one kind of bottom line thing
for the committee chair is that
he has to take- he or she
has to take- an attitude of servant leadership
and look at his or her role
as a role of support
and service to not only the scout master
and the assistant scout masters,
but to other committee members as well.
the committee chair needs to be up on all the latest
BSA practices
and policies and all
of the guides that come out.
ideally should be the first one,
or one of the first, to bring these new things,
like the new advancement guide, into the troop
and to believe in
and encourage and support the patrol method,
which means doing his or her best to keep the adults
out of the way
and for messing things up for the boys.
I think that's probably
one of the biggest roles that the
committee chair should
fill.
well, if anyone has great ideas
recruiting the next committee chair, I'm open.
how long has your committee chairman been there,
Walter?
a couple of years,
okay, so
it's not been like eight or ten years or something.
no, no,
no, he's starting up at a
new job which is going to take a lot of time.
so you don't think
the next one
is right there.
there are some people who
who could be,
but just getting somebody to
step up is really the question,
right, yeah? well, the
thing is is you don't ever want to wait.
when the right guy is there,
make the move,
don't wait too long.
yeah, I really think the thing that you need to do,
the very first thing you need to do in taking a new job,
is to recruit your replacement right away,
so that you'll have somebody to back you up
in case that happens, in case you have to leave.
I have a couple of people in mind
who might be interested
in stepping in someday.
so you know, it's always a good idea
to have that in mind.
I think a lot of times, Walter,
my experience has been, if you approach people
from the idea of what their function
is going to be rather than the title
you have to take on,
people are usually a little bit
easier when you ask them to
perform a function.
well, we need somebody who's going to run committee meetings
and, you know,
make an agenda and make sure
that things are happening, and
I've had
better luck recruiting with the job description
rather than with the title.
how about that?
yeah, I think
actually that does work, to have
some description of what's going on.
and for a lot of the jobs you say,
fair share is just a couple
of months here. if there's a time,
the wreath sales are just November
or December.
that's the
limits of that job.
so, Clark, how's that work? for scout master:
hey, do you want to be scout master?
or hey,
do you want me to throw you in this room
with 35 12 year olds
and leave you alone and say goodbye?
most of the time,
most of the time
now, you would never want to give a scout
master an introduction by giving him
a job description. good lord,
none of us would have done it. I don't
think
every time we get new
parents- and I'm always on the lookout
for, just in case
you know,
if one of them could
actually step in
and do that if I had to
listen. I really appreciate everybody spending
the time this evening.
Frank, out of no by
Michigan committee chair.
I've been planning on it.
we'll make sure to send everybody over
to take a look at the blog. thanks for spending
the time with us tonight. it's been fun
and a pleasure, Clark. Larry,
it's good to meet you, Frank. thank you, Larry,
Tom, nice being with you tonight.
good meeting you too, Frank. thanks, Tom
and Walter, can you still see
the mountain? yes, then, the sun is just
behind the Santa Cruz mountain, so it's time
to say good night. thanks again,
fellas.
well, thank you so much for listening to this edition
of the scout master podcast. now just to fill
in a couple of things. for the uninitiated
Walter who participated
in the podcast, it's Walter Underwood.
Underwood, just like the typewriter,
if you go back that far.
and Walter does, and so do I
also.
we mentioned to Bob White a few times,
and a Bob White is one of the
patrol names that is given to a
patrol of leaders going through Wood Badge.
they're different animal patrol
names that people get,
so that might help clear that up a little bit.
right? hey,
here's how you can keep in touch with this
all. you can read the scout master blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and there you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog and the podcast
by email. you can subscribe
to the scout master podcast on iTunes
and when you do, please leave a comment or review
a rating. that's always nice.
you can also access the podcast
on your mobile device through Stitcher
smart radio. you can get details about
how to make that happen at stitchercom.
call and leave a voicemail, comment or question at
484-734-0002.
I've had a couple recently that did not
record well enough for me to be able to broadcast
and I didn't have a way of getting back to
the people who called. so give it another try,
please.
if you haven't heard yourself on the podcast,
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social
media outlets.
that's right. you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
scoutmastercg on Twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle, search for
scoutmastercg on Google plus.
alright, so you don't mess around
with Facebook. you don't tweet
on Twitter and you don't plus on
Google, that's alright.
that's no problem, bunkie, you can email me.
you can zoom right into the late 90s
and email me with your comments,
your questions and wild ideas
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
did you know the scoutmaster blog and the
scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America? Nope,
they sure aren't. nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me talking into a microphone
and every once in a while I convince
other people to do the same, and we're
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe just have a little bit of fun along the way.
before we leave you, let's hear from our
Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you
and good camping,
why? thank you, sir,
until next time.